we've been talking about the issue of
fake news and also propaganda news for a
long time now and I've also been very
very positive for a long time about Elon
Musk
as an entrepreneur about Tesla SpaceX so
on and so forth but today I have to tell
you that Elon Musk has a genuinely bad
idea about journalism and fake news and
news sources and this story today
sponsored by ground ground is a mobile
app that lets you see all sides of
breaking news stories and what it does
is assemble news stories by verifying
information written by the major news
websites with local news sources on the
ground using their news map interface
and sort of taking a proactive approach
to prevent misinformation from spreading
around very important very ambitious
undertaking and you can check out the
ground app on iOS and Android doesn't
cost anything and we're linking to it in
the YouTube description Elon Musk's idea
is to crowdsource ratings of
journalistic credibility and he went on
Twitter and accused journalists of a
sort of holier-than-thou double standard
and also blamed the media for getting
Donald Trump elected but then he said
what about a media credibility rating
website where he said quote going to
create a site where the public can rate
the core truth of any article and track
the credibility score over time of each
journalist editor and publication
thinking of calling it Pravda even if
some of the public doesn't care about
the credibility score the journalists
editors and publications will it is how
they define themselves and the way that
it would work I guess is that the public
would rate the truth level of any
article and it would start to assign
credibility scores to individual
journalists or editors and publications
and there are good motivations here
right he clearly wants to hold media
accountable he wants to establish a way
to differentiate between actual news
reporting and propaganda news and fake
news all three of which are different
things the problem in a way is that the
biases of the people visiting the
website and doing the rating are going
to skew the rankings of the media
outlets and you're going to effectively
end up with the exact same thing we have
now right if you have right-wingers now
who say Fox News can be trusted you'll
have right-wingers going to
website and voting for Fox News as a
trustworthy entity because that's what
Elon Musk's website allows them to be
and you're gonna end up with basically
the exact same thing now even if that
didn't happen in quite that way a feel
on Musk's website gains the power that
Elon Musk wants it to have wouldn't
reporters maybe start writing stories in
the way that they predict will get the
highest ratings on Elon Musk's website
rather than the way that they think is
the right way to write the story that
also would be a really bad thing and
then there's another issue which is
pointed out by a pretty good article on
salon.com which is that it's really hard
for people to evaluate what's true sort
of in the absence of the bias that they
bring into it right if you go in to a
news article believing that something is
true you're more likely to say the
article is accurate if it comes firms
your beliefs and you're more likely to
say the article is inaccurate if it
doesn't confirm your belief so I
actually think that this is not a good
idea even though the intentions are good
what would be a good way to do this
you know Trump talked about the
government basically saying we're gonna
tell you what's the list of fake news
and what's the list of real news that's
a disaster right the last thing we want
is a government running that I think
that the best solution and it's not a
perfect solution is some kind of non
media non-government entity which ranks
Meuse sources on specific sets of
criteria right accuracy of basic facts
hiding opinion journalism within
so-called news reporting proper sourcing
we would establish some set of criteria
how you pay for it
I don't know how do you ensure that it's
done with that political violet bias I'm
not really sure but I think that
something along those lines is the best
shot we have at really rating and
ranking news sources
yeah there are plenty of things you
could put up to a vote like what people
like and what they don't like who they
want representing them but this just
isn't one of them because it's not the
general public's interest I guess to
assess credibility do all that
background research that fact-checking
the average person either won't do it or
incapable of incapable of doing it
because their implicit biases yeah
there's also a self-selection bias
because not everybody would even be in
in rating news right so you're also
going to get massive self selection bias
based on who it is that it would even
occur to to go on the website and say
I'm gonna rank news outlets so I think
that the motivations are fine the idea
is a disaster and I would love to hear
from people in the audience how would
you establish the closest thing to a
truly unbiased and absolutely
nonpartisan but also non-governmental
and also the media outlets can't be
involved in it the last thing you want
is media outlets being involved in any
way in the entity that is going to rank
their accuracy send me your thoughts how
would you do it